はじめ：結局あいつが悪いんだよ。
たなっち：いやでもー
はじめ：いやでも俺じゃないよあれは
たなっち：でもみんなは、そう思ってる
はじめ：キムラヤで万引きしてるの見たよ。
たなっち ：万引きしてないよ、あれは当たったんだよ。
はじめ；いや～でも見たんだよ、万引したの
はじめ；なんか亮介ね自分の書きかたにうるさいの
たなっち；うわ！やば！
はじめ：俺知らないんだもん。してないんだもん
子供：したよ、したよ。　はじめ：したよな！
子供：いや、してないでしょ
子供たち；した、した。たなっち；本当はしたって言ってた。
はじめ；いや、でもしてないとも言ってたし
だいちぃ；おい江田！やふへゐ；おい江田！
だいちぃ；宿題代わりにやってよ
はじめ；無理だ、なんでだよ ！　よふへゐ；なんでだよ
はじめ；なんだよ、いやだいやだ
はじめ；いやだよ。なんにもしてないじゃん。やめてよ。
よふへゐ；数学やってくれよ。
はじめ；やめてよ、数学じゃない、ここやめて♡
[イジメ]
だいちぃ；頼むぞこれ
やふへゐ：頼んだぞ江田
やふへゐ；また二学期もよろしくな。
だいちぃ、やふへゐ；あははははははははははｈ
はじめ；夏休みだ♡
はじめ；ヒャッホーーーーーー
やんちゃ三人；いちゃいちゃ
はじめ；俊介の家、今日誰もいないし俊介の家に行こう
やふへゐ：今日ちょっと俺んち駄目なんだよ
はじめ；おまえんちのカントリーマーム全部食っていい？
よふへゐ；いやーちょっと
はじめ；こいつの家の棚にカントリーマームめっちゃあるんだよ。
だいちぃ；まじで！！！！
はじめ、だいちぃ；あはははははははははははは
はじめ；[涙]
はじめ；あ！くそーーー
はじめ；ごめん、撃たれたー
はじめ；ちくしょー、もう一回
はじめ；ZZZZZZZZZZZ
はじめ；あ、亮介君？宿題全部見せて
はじめのお母さん；はじめー？今日から二学期じゃないの？
はじめのお母さん；早く行きなさい学校
はじめのお母さん；杉田君来てるわよ
杉田君：お邪魔しまーす。江田くん、二学期始まるよ
杉田君：ね、江田くん。学校始まるってｗ
はじめ：行きたくない泣。
杉田君；え？何言ってるの。
はじめ；俺、もう行かないよ
杉田君：ダメだってはじめくん学校始まるって。
はじめ：行きたくないんだよ。
杉田君：無理矢理でも引っ張っていくよ
はじめ：無理だよ、俺行きたくないもん。まだ夏休み終わってないもん
はじめ：俺無理、俺無理。
杉田君；ダメだって
よふへゐ；夏休み明けでさぁ、テスト全然できなかったんだよね。
だいちぃ；おれもだよ。
よふへゐ；算数難しすぎるんだよね
ようへゐ；追いつけないよ、もう本当に
て↓れ↑て↓れ↑て↓れ↑て↓れ↑て↓れ↑て↓れ↑
てててて☆
はじめ：おう、久しぶり